okay so uh joe biden's approval ratings
are just absolutely in the toilet
there's a new poll out from ini and tipp
and it shows that joe biden is swirling
the drain
the poll asked who do you want to see
run for president on the democratic
ticket in 2024 joe biden was named by 22
percent of those asked
said vice president kamala harris none
of the rest of the democrats rose above
single digits the much beloved booty
judge garnered four percent aoc
elizabeth warren massachusetts
representative joe kennedy for some
reason and stacey abrams each attracted
three percent support
meanwhile six percent of all those who
answered preferred someone other than
those on the list 31
said they were unsure
if the numbers suck only 37 percent of
democrats say they are enthused about
joe biden holding the top spot and only
say they want kamal harris and no one
even gets more than low single-digit
support after that
the numbers for joe biden continue to
decline there's another poll out today
and shows voters pessimistic about the
economy biden's leadership is according
to a new wall street journal poll
the survey according to the wall street
journal reveals a set of danger signs
for the democratic party as it prepares
to defend narrow majorities in the house
and senate voters by a large margin see
economic and fiscal issues including
inflation as top priorities for
washington and they view the gop as
better able to handle them
joe biden's overall approval rating
right now is at 41
his disapproval is at 57
what's much worse for joe biden he
strongly approve of joe biden number is
he's strongly disapproved of joe biden
number is 46 percent
so you got 22 percent of the american
public saying they somewhat approve of
joe biden and 10 percent saying they
somewhat disapprove but people hate him
much more than they love him for sure
more voters apparently say they would
back a republican than a democrat for
congress 44 to 41 of the election were
held today that is within the polls
margin of error
but again most of these polls tend to
underestimate republican support and
republican turnout
so these numbers are really really bad
for the democrats right now
and as far as whether the country is on
the right track or in the wrong on the
wrong track according to that wall
street journal
of americans say the country is on the
wrong track only 27 say the country is
on the right track
some 61 percent of americans say the
economy is headed in the wrong direction
some 46 of americans expect the economy
to get worse next year compared with 30
to expect it to get better
margin in favor of the proposition that
inflation is going to get worse rather
than better
people have really bad expectations with
regard to crime by a 33-point margin
people think the crime is going to get
worse not better 26 more americans think
that the border is going to get worse
not better
the nation's political divide 50 point
margin between people who say it's going
to get worse and people who say it's
going to get better
on the issues the gop has an advantage
on the economy inflation and securing
the border
democrats have an advantage on getting
the pandemic under control but again
those numbers are not particularly
stellar on improving education it's
fairly evenly split on making health
care affordable democrats have an
advantage but the issues americans care
most about rebuilding the economy and
getting inflation under control
republicans have massive advantages
so democrats have a real problem on
their hands but the bigger issue here is
that americans just seem consumed with
the idea that the future is going to
suck
and and i think one of the reasons that
they feel consumed with the idea of the
future is going to suck
is because we as a country seem to have
lost purpose
the surgeon general of the united states
came out yesterday and he announced that
we have a mental health crisis among
young americans which again if you watch
tick tock for any length of time at all
you know is true
you can view my review videos over at
youtube where i go through some of what
goes on on tick tock and it is basically
just a mental asylum in full public view
for the walls it's a bunch of people who
are who are signifying their real mental
disorders
and doing so for people to cheer them
the surgeon general had put out this 53
page report today talking about how
children are in real trouble
to the surgeon general he says recent
national surveys of young people have
shown alarming increases in the
prevalence of certain mental health
challenges in 2019 one in three high
school students and half of all female
students reported persistent feelings of
sadness or hopelessness an overall
increase of 40 from 2009
since 2009 okay we're not talking from
30 years ago we're talking about just
over the course of the last 12 years an
increase of 40 percent
according to the government of course
this is shaped by
social media it is shaped by
drug use it chip but that doesn't go to
any of the real underlying issues that
are that are innervating the society
according to the government quote we
know that mental health is shaped by
many factors from our genes and brain
chemistry to our relationships with
family and friends neighborhood
conditions and larger social forces and
policies we also know that too often
young people are bombarded with messages
through the media and popular culture
that erodes their sense of self-worth
telling them they are not good-looking
enough popular enough smart enough or
rich enough that comes as progress on
legitimate and distressing issues like
climate change income inequality racial
injustice the opioid epidemic and gun
violence feels too slow
of course the u.s surgeon general is
saying the reason that kids are now
suicidal is because we haven't done
enough on climate change or income
inequality or racial justice
or alternatively there's a giant gaping
hole in the soul of america's young
people
and in some of its older people that is
not going to be filled by your bull crap
excuses for for motivation on a daily
basis
the government is also blaming
technology platforms they say we're not
deployed responsibly and safely these
tools can pit us against each other
reinforce negative behaviors like
bullying and exclusion and undermine the
safe and supportive environments young
people need and deserve all that was
true before covet 19 dramatically
altered young people's experiences at
home at school and in the community the
pandemic era's unfathomable number of
deaths pervasive sense of fear economic
instability and forced physical
distancing from loved ones friends and
communities have exacerbated the
unprecedented stresses young people
already face
our obligation tax is not just medical
it's moral says vivek murthy the surgeon
general of the united states okay so
according to the surgeon general the
reason that we're having a mental health
crisis is because we're not doing all
the things that the left wants you to do
via the government and that of course is
really silly so first they try to claim
that mental health conditions that have
gotten much more grave among america's
young people that that is due to
biological factors
nah in order to assume that it's due to
biological factors you would have to
assume that over the last 12 years there
has been a major change in the biology
of human minds which not a lot of
evidence do suggest that
environmental factors yes
according to vivek murthy some mental
health disorders seem to cluster in
families they're often shaped by
multiple genes whether an individual
develops symptoms can be further
modified by experiences and surrounding
environment
environmental factors can range from
exposure to alcohol or drugs during
pregnancy to birth complications to
discrimination and racism to adverse
childhood experiences such as abuse
neglect exposure to community violence
and living in under-resourced or
racially segregated neighborhoods okay
some of these are well substantiated the
notion that if you suffer from
discrimination that this leads to
massive mental health crises the the
suicide the suicidal ideation stats
don't really back that up in fact it
tends to be middle upper class white
people who have higher levels of
suicidal ideation than for example
impoverished black people
so if it's really about class issues
then it that or race issues that really
doesn't explain it
they say that
adverse childhood experiences can
undermine a child's sense of safety
stability bonding and well-being
moreover
aces again those are adverse childhood
experiences may lead to the development
of toxic stress which can cause
long-lasting change and of course the
answer to all of this is the government
getting involved in everything so they
put together a graphic adopted from the
w.h.o talking about factors that can
shape the mental health of young people
and here is what your government says
social and economic inequalities
discrimination racism migration media
and technology popular culture and
government policies all can exacerbate
mental health problems
neighborhood safety access to green
spaces like parks healthy food housing
healthcare pollution natural disasters
and climate change this is going to
affect your mental health climate change
is going to affect your mental health
relationship with peers teachers and
mentors faith communities school climate
academic pressure community support
relationship with parents basically
everything in life can affect your
mental health but what has changed right
this is the big question what has
changed since 2009 to 2019
according to the surgeon general report
from 2009 to 2019 the proportion of high
school students reporting persistent
feelings of sadness or hopelessness
increased by 40 percent the share
seriously considering attempting suicide
increased by 36 that's a huge number the
share creating a suicide plan increased
by 44
between 2015 and 2011 and 2015 youth
psychiatric visits to emergency
departments for depression anxiety and
behavioral challenges increased by 28
between 2007 and 2018 suicide rates
among youth aged to 24 in the united
states increased by 57
early estimates from the national center
for health statistics suggest there were
more than 6 600 deaths by suicide among
the 10 to 24 age group in 2020 alone
scientists propose various hypotheses to
to explain all of this
they say that it might be more people
discussing mental health concerns but
they also are blaming digital media
increasing academic pressure uh i i'm
gonna have to hear why increasing
academic pressure is causing this
considering that our schools are
underperforming and there's less
academic pressure to perform in modern
america than at any time in recent
american history
they talk about income inequality
exacerbating this sort of stuff which is
weird because we didn't have this sort
of spiking depression and suicide rate
during the you know great depression
they talk about racism and gun violence
and climate change as factors again it
all comes back to there's a problem in
society and it must be our favorite
solutions that are the actual solutions
now if you are going to examine what is
wrong with the utes what exactly is
happening with the youth
you would have to go a little bit deeper
than this
right so they talk about some of the
things that have been exacerbated during
the
pandemic they say that if you've lived
in an urban area or an area with more
severe cover 19 outbreaks this is
exacerbated mental health problems if
you are worried about covet 19 if you
experience disruptions and routine which
by the way would suggest that the
lockdowns did much more damage to kids
than actual coven 19 because the number
again of people under the age of 18 in
the united states where healthy who've
died of cover 19 across the entirety of
the pandemic is somewhere between 10 and
20 according to marty mccary of johns
hopkins university so when you're
talking about why young people are
depressed because of coven it isn't
because they're scared of covet or if
they are scared of covetous because the
adults are idiots
and the reason is because they've been
locked in their homes and told that they
cannot see other human beings
okay but the the bigger problem here is
that again the the government's
suggestions as to why we are seeing
mental health problems across young
people in the united states are always
geared toward what can the government do
to fix it and the problem is
that this is not predominantly a
governmental issue this is predominantly
a philosophical issue that has now
boiled down to how we raise our children
or if we even have children at all
some of the most durable statistics in
in mental well-being show that for
example religious people tend to be less
suicidal they tend to have less suicidal
ideation than people who are less
religious
there there's good evidence to suggest
that class has very little to do with it
there's good evidence to suggest that
rate has very little to do with it and
certainly climate change has very little
to do with it
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe